[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOEL NEWMAN: Good afternoon,
everybody, and welcome.
Today's session is all
about app performance.
My name is Joel Newman, and
I'm a product specialist
on the Google Play
business development team.
In that capacity, I've worked
with Android developers
of all shapes and
sizes, helping them
to leverage the tools available
in the Google Play Console
to build successful
app businesses.
Now I'm going to kick things
off with a quick reminder
of just how important
performance is to app business
success, and why
Android Vitals could
be a critical tool in helping
you improve your performance.
Then my colleague
Fergus, product manager
for Android Vitals, will join
me on stage to talk about some
of the ways we're
enhancing the platform
to make it easier to understand
and to action your performance
information.
Then my colleague, [INAUDIBLE],,
from our developer relations
team will come onstage
for a technical deep dive
to talk through some of the
common causes of performance
issues and how to address them.
Finally, we'll wrap things
up by talking about some
of the resources available
within the Play Console
itself and beyond to
improve your performance.
And if we have time, we'll
try to do a brief Q&A.
Now, first, I think it's
important to remind ourselves
of why performance is important.
Now, I think this
is intuitive, right?
Like we, as users,
nobody wants to deal
with an app that crashes
frequently or freezes
or is janky.
But at Google Play,
we have data that
drives home just how
important performance is.
We did an analysis of all the
reviews on the Google Play
Store over the
past year and found
that when leaving a one-star
review, over 40% of the time,
users cited negative
performance indicators
like stability and bugs.
In fact, this was the
number one cited issue
within one-star reviews.
Now, on the flip side, when
leaving five-star reviews,
over 70% of users mentioned
positive performance
indicators, things like
speed, design, and usability.
Now, why is this important?
Well, not only are
ratings and reviews
a direct and leading indicator
of customer satisfaction,
and not only do ratings figure
heavily in the Play Store
search algorithm, but ratings
and reviews correlate strongly
with downstream
business KPIs, things
like engagement, retention,
and monetization.
A great example of
how that performance
can impact key business
KPIs comes from this study.
We did an analysis of all
of the games in Google Play.
And we compared those with the
lowest crash rate versus those
of the highest crash rate.
And we found apps with
the lower crash rate
saw almost two and
a half minutes more
of game play per day.
And this was even
a bigger trend when
we looked at ANRs, which are
more frequently looked over
relative to crash rate.
We found that users spent almost
three minutes more per day
in the more stable apps.
Now, this may not sound
like a ton of time.
But when you look at
this over a yearly basis,
this would translate
into 18 hours
of additional gameplay
per user for games that
are played on a daily basis.
Now, another reason
why performance
is incredibly
important is that it's
becoming an increasingly
important signal
within Google Play for
both search and discovery.
As Google Play is committed
to servicing only the highest
content to our users,
we're increasingly
taking into account performance
signals, particularly
those related to stability
and battery consumption,
in both our Play Store
search algorithm,
as well as our algorithmically
generated recommendations.
In addition to that,
performance signals factor
heavily into our decisions
around our editorially curated
content.
This includes our featured new
and updated apps collection,
as well as editors' choice
and coveted Google Play
Awards and Android Excellence.
If you want your app
business to succeed,
your app needs to be discovered.
And technical performance
is an increasing part
of that discovery
within the Play Store.
Now, it's exactly because of
that increasing importance
of technical performance that
we launched Android Vitals
last year.
Android Vitals is an
initiative by Google
to improve the stability and
performance of Android devices
by servicing to
developers in an easily
understandable and
readily accessible
way the most important
performance metrics
in battery, stability,
and rendering.
This comes from over
100 million users
who have opted in to
share the data with Google
and with you, our
developer partners.
And since the program's
launch a year ago, it's
been an incredible success.
We have over 100,000 developers,
including some of the biggest
names on the Android
platform, regularly engaging
with the Vitals Console to
understand their performance
issue and create fixes.
Now, it's because of this
incredible engagement
that we've seen some really nice
gains at an ecosystem level.
When we compared reviews in the
Play Store today versus a year
ago before we
launched Vitals, we
see a really nice uptick
in those people leaving
five-star reviews talking about
things like speed, design,
and usability.
But perhaps more
importantly, when
we look at people
leaving one-star reviews,
we've seen an
almost 20% decrease
in the number of people talking
about things like stability
and bugs and
battery consumption.
And that's only possible
because of the incredible work
that you have done as
a developer community
to up the quality
of Android apps.
And for those of you who
are new to the platform,
it's really important
that you keep pace
with the rest of the
developer community who
is helping us move in a
positive performance direction.
Now, I think, while these
gains at an ecosystem level
are interesting,
you might wonder
as an individual
developer, yeah,
but how does that
really matter to me?
Well, I want to showcase
a couple of examples
of where individual developers
have seen incredible gains
because of Android Vitals.
One of my favorite case
studies is Starbucks.
Now, Starbucks is obviously
an incredibly popular app.
They have over 15
million downloads
on the Google Play Store.
They started using Android
Vitals in December,
admittedly, several months
after the launch of the program.
Now, when they started
using Android Vitals,
they were alerted
to ANR issues that
were not even on their radar.
And they were able to use
the reporting in the console
to identify common underlying
causes for the ANRs
that were caused by a
third party library.
They removed that
third party library,
and saw a 70% reduction
in ANR rate within a week.
Now, they saw a similar,
and actually even better,
experience with crash rate.
Because Android Vitals
is a platform-level tool,
it's able to detect crashes that
were not detected by Starbucks'
third party crash SDK, because
these crashes were happening
at app start before
Starbucks' third party
crash SDK had even initiated.
Using the Vitals
reporting, they were
able to identify an
underlying cause, push a fix,
and they saw an 85% reduction
in crash rate within a week.
These are impressive stats.
Now, it's worth calling
out that Vitals,
and this is the
common misconception,
is not just for apps.
It's equally relevant for games.
A great example comes
from Kiloo, developers
of the super popular Subway
Surfers app, which was actually
the first game to
pass the 1 billion
install mark on Google Play.
When Subway Surfers started
using Android Vitals,
they discovered a sudden
increase in ANR rate,
used the reports to identify
a cause, and pushed a fix,
and saw a reduction of
their ANR rate from 2%
to below 0.1%, a 95% reduction.
But I think what's
worth calling out here
is what we found afterward.
So we did an analysis
at Google Play
of what was the change of
engagement with the app
before and after the fix.
And we saw really
substantive gains
in both daily active users
and in sessions for users
across the board.
Now, these are just two
examples of developers
who have been able to
leverage the platform
to see really significant
gains both at a performance
and a business level.
Now I'm going to
invite up Fergus,
product manager for Vitals,
who's going to talk about some
of the ways that we're enhancing
the platform to make it even
more powerful for developers.
FERGUS HURLEY: Great job.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Fergus Hurley, product
manager for Android Vitals.
It's been incredible
to see the improvements
that app developers, like
yourselves, have made
over the past year as a
result of using the tools
that we've made available.
It's also been incredible to
get all the feedback from you as
to how we can improve
Android Vitals.
I'm really excited to
show you the new features
we have available today as
a result of your feedback.
So thank you so much.
Last year, when we
announced Android Vitals,
as Joel mentioned, we launched
three performance areas,
battery, stability,
and rendering.
Today, we're announcing
two new areas, startup time
and permissions.
Battery is probably the most
important performance area
to focus on.
This is where you
should not unnecessarily
use the CPU or the radios
on the device, which
drains the users'
batteries, which means they
can't use your app as long.
Stability is all about
building a robust and reliable
application, so the users
are using your application
without freezes or crashes.
And rendering is all about
building a fast and responsive
application that's silky
smooth and doesn't lag or stall
on users.
With startup time,
we're enabling
you to be able to
provide a quick launching
application to your users, no
matter what state your app has
been in.
There's three different
metrics we have here.
And I'm going to go
through each one.
So, first, we have
slow cold start.
Slow here is defined as
five seconds or more.
And cold start is
when your app has not
been launched in a
while, and is going
from activity launched
to activity running,
and the app is not in memory.
Slow warm start is where it
takes two seconds or more
for your app to go from activity
launched to activity running,
where your app is in memory.
Final startup time metric
we have is slow hot start.
This is where your app goes from
onRestart to activity running.
And it takes longer
than 1.5 seconds.
This is where your app and
your activity is in memory.
Another new performance
area we have is permissions.
This is where we want to help
you be able to only request
permissions that users
think are required
for the core value
of your application
to be provided to them.
And if they don't think so,
then provide them justification
why you think they
should actually
provide that information.
When we ask users,
"What are the reasons
that you deny permissions
for applications?",
what we find is that the
vast majority of them
just think that the app
doesn't need those permissions.
So really providing
a justification
is critical for you to get
users to be able to give you
the permission
that you need to be
able to offer the best
functionality possible
in your application.
In the details view
for permissions,
we provide a breakdown
by permission group.
So, maybe one of your
permissions users
think your app does need,
and you get a high percentage
of acceptance for that one.
And then another one,
users don't think you need,
and you get a high
denial rate for that one.
And maybe you don't need that
permission in the first place.
So maybe you should rethink it.
Or maybe you just need to
explain to users why your app
does need that permission.
We have many other breakdowns
across the Vitals product.
For most Vitals, we break
it down by app version,
by device, and by
Android version.
For wake locks and
wakeups, we provide by tag.
For ANRs, we provide by
ANR type and ANR name.
We also provide
the clusters view
for grouping your
ANRs together, so you
can be able to see
which ones are similar,
and be able to debug
those clusters.
For crashes, we also
provide clusters.
When I've been building
apps at Google, and prior
to Google, one of the things
I struggled with the most was
being able to
understand, how do I
compare with other apps that
offer similar functionality?
Who else has struggled
with understanding
if their app is performing
well compared to other apps?
OK, lots of people share the
same struggle as I've had.
We are now going to announce
category level benchmarks
in the Play Console.
This enables you to be able
to see, OK, for start time,
you can see here, that
board games are much faster
at starting than racing games.
And we also provide the 25th,
50th and 75th percentile
breakdown for each of the
category level benchmarks.
We'll default to the category
that you list yourself
in the store, but you can
select any other category
that you want to be able
to compare yourself with,
in case you don't think
that your app is as related
to that category.
On the details page
for every vital,
we show you this breakdown
for the category benchmark.
And then you can
be able to also see
what exact percentage you are
relative to the other apps
in that category.
On the redesigned Android
Vitals overview page,
we show you each of the metrics
in the performance area.
We show you what was your
percentage of users impacted
in the last 30 days, what
was the percentage of users
impacted in the
previous 30 days,
and we show you the
benchmark comparison.
This enables you to
be to quickly see, OK,
which one of these
performance areas
should I actually look into?
And which specific metric
might require more attention?
And so you can see here,
the last one on the list.
You're in the bottom 12%.
That's probably when
you want to investigate.
The Weather Channel has
been an early access partner
for these features that
we're showing today
for the past couple of weeks.
And one of the pieces of
feedback that they've had
is it's been really
great for them
to be able to use
category level benchmarks
to make the case
within their company
as to why they should invest
in performance, because they
can show how they stack
up versus competing apps.
I hope you're able to use
similar data to be able to make
the case within your company.
If you want to learn more about
benchmarks in the Play Console,
we have a session
tomorrow at 9:30 AM.
Although all Android
Vitals should
be viewed as ways to
be able to enhance
the experience of
your application,
some vitals are more important
to offering the best user
experience possible.
And so that's why we're
putting this feature
at the top of the
Android Vitals overview
page, which is core vitals.
These are the vitals that you
should pay most attention to.
These are the ones that will
impact your promotability
and ranking in the store,
along with many other signals.
But you should really pay
attention to these signals.
You'll see the
list of the vitals.
Here we have the initial four.
So, stop partial
wakelocks, where
you hold a wakelock for over
an hour in the background.
Excessive wakeups,
where you have
10 wakeups happening per hour.
ANR rate, where you have
a user experience the app
not responding for five
seconds or more in a day.
And a crash rate, where they
have one crash in a day.
If you're in the bottom 25%
for any of these core vitals,
then you'll be flagged
as having a bad behavior.
This is where you'll
see a tile at the top
of the core vital
section to alert you.
And when you click
on that tile, you'll
be able to go into
the details view,
and see which specific APK is
exhibiting that bad behavior.
And we provide you
the information
to help you debug that issue.
One of the major
requests that we've
had over the past
year is to get alerted
when there is an issue that's
introduced with their vitals.
And so we're really happy to
announce anomaly detection.
So this is where
you'll get flagged
with an alert at the top of
your Android Vital section,
are they in crash clusters,
to let you know what
is the issue that you have.
And you can click
on that tile and be
able to go in and see details.
You can also be able to
sign up to get email alerts,
when one of these
anomalis is detected.
And when you get
one of those emails,
there's a link
directly to the issue.
So you can be able
to investigate.
OK, when did this issue occur?
And for how long did it happen?
The Big Fish games team that
have built many games that
have reached over
10 million installs
have found great results
using these tools
by being an early access
partner for these features
over the past couple of months.
And they've reduced
their crash rate
by 45% for one of
their top games.
I'm now going to
hand over to Wojtek
to talk about how you can debug
and improve your specific core
vitals issues.
WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
Thank you, Fergus.
So, hi, everyone.
My name is Wojtek.
I work on the Developer
Relations team.
And I work closely with
the Android teams at Google
to help you developers
build better apps.
And today I want
to talk about how
you can fix some of
these core vitals
that Fergus mentioned in
your apps, in your code.
And, first, I want to
start with stability.
And let's talk a
little bit about ANRs.
So we keep saying this
acronym, right, ANRs,
but what are they really?
So ANRs, in other
words, application not
responding events.
Now this happens
whenever in your app
some long running operation
blocks your main thread.
Now, the main thread is
responsible for things
like responding to user
events, such as taps
or redrawing the
UI for every frame.
So if we block it, if the
main thread cannot do that
in a timely manner, the
app will just seem frozen.
And then after a few seconds,
the system will notice that,
and will pop up this
annoying dialogue
that lets the user
actually close the app.
And as developers, we really
don't want that to happen.
So what are some
common causes of ANRs.
What kind of operations
can block our main thread?
Well, probably the most common
ones are network and disk
operations, also call this I/O.
Now, networks are congested.
Remote servers are slow.
So can be our flash
drives, or the file system
can be busy with
other operations.
And so, as developers, we should
never, never do network or disk
operations on the main thread.
But I just prepared
two code examples
to show you that it's not always
easy to do the right thing.
Even though you all
probably agree with me,
we can still make mistakes.
So here, for example,
in my activity onCreate,
I decided, well, I'm
just going to prepare
this shared preferences
object to use later.
I'm just going to
create it and not
do anything with it right now.
And then somewhere
else in my app,
probably on a
background thread, I
will actually get
some information,
like read an integer,
or string, or whatever.
And I thought, OK, that's good.
I will not be doing disk
operations on a main thread.
What I didn't
realize, though, is
that the implementation of
shared preferences on Android
actually eagerly
reads data from disk
the moment you create them.
So that's actually the line
of code that does disk access.
So I was wrong.
It's not always obvious.
And let me show you another,
even trickier example.
So here, I'm doing some
hypothetical network operations
in my app.
So let's say I want to
check if my intent contains
some kind of URL So
I'm comparing the two.
And then I say I want to
open connection to that URL.
I'm going to save the headers
to some variable for later use.
And then I actually
open an input stream.
And finally,
finally, in the end,
I am reading bytes
from the network.
So this is a pretty
complicated API, to be honest.
And how am I as a
developer supposed
to know if that first line,
openConnection, creates
the network request and
actually blocks my thread?
Or is it the last
one, where I actually
request to read bytes of
data, to actually read them
into my application?
Or is it something else?
And, well, it's not obvious.
Actually, in this
example, this line of code
will perform a
network operation.
The first time I'm
trying to access headers,
only then will the
connection be opened,
and the first
bytes will be read.
And so, as a developer,
again, I failed.
I didn't know which operation
does the network access.
But, fun fact, on an even older
Android version, this line,
just checking if URLs are equal,
can perform network operations.
OK, so why am I
showing you all this?
Because I want to convince
you that, as developers,
we cannot know everything.
And you will use
libraries that you're not
familiar with, or other APIs.
And that's why I suggest you
use StrictMode for your debug
builds while you
develop your apps.
Now, StrictMode is an API
that existed on Android
for a long time.
And it's pretty easy to set up.
You just set a thread
policy in your application
on Create, or in your
activity onCreate,
and you tell
StrictMode, I want you
to detect all disk operations in
my application on this thread.
And I also want you to
detect network operations.
And then you tell StrictMode
what you want the result to be.
So, first of all, of course,
we want to see it in logs,
so we can debug it later.
But logs are easy to miss, like
LogCat can be noisy sometimes.
So for my debug
builds, I'm also going
to go and say penaltyDeath,
which will actually
crash my app whenever I do the
wrong thing and access network
or disk on the main thread.
Now, like I said,
you don't want to do
any of that in your
production release builds,
because you don't want
your users app to crash.
OK, so now I go back and run
my code that I just showed you
and look at my logs, because
my app obviously crashed.
And I see the exact cause.
And I can go and debug that.
So I can see there was a
StrictMode discrete violation.
And I can see in
the stack trace,
the culprit is, yeah, it's the
getDefaultSharedPreferences
call that I did in my
activity on Create.
So, great, this lets me
actually go and fix that.
OK, so we covered network
and disk operations
and how to catch them.
Sometimes you don't even need
to hit remote servers or disk
to cause a long
running operation.
All it takes is literally
just calculating something
for a long time, doing a
very long loop, and something
like that.
So here, in this example,
this is a simple Sudoku game.
And how it works is, when
the user opens the app,
the Sudoku board is actually
generated in memory.
It's not read from disk.
It's not pulled down
from a server somewhere.
There's actually a pretty
long complex calculation
happening to show that
first board to the user,
so they can play it.
And so it's just one
call, generateBoard.
And, as you can see,
on a slow device,
this could cause
an ANR, because I'm
doing that on the main thread.
So, first of all,
how am I supposed
to know, as a developer, that
this call, generateBoard, can
be long?
Well, I really suggest that you
use Android Profiler regularly
if you ever suspect
there is any performance
problem in your app.
So here, for example,
I took a CPU trace
of the method generateBoard
in the Android Profiler,
and I can immediately
see that it's
a complex, recursive
call that takes
a long, long time to finish.
And so now I know I
should not be running it
on the main thread
Oh, and by the way,
there's a new thing
in the Android
Profiler that we just
released in [INAUDIBLE] today.
Now you can debug and profile
your app startup time.
So that's pretty handy.
OK, so going back to our problem
with our generateBoard call.
What can I do with it?
So StrictMode has this
method of telling it
that a call can be slow.
So here, as a developer, as the
person who created this Sudoku
algorithm, I will
tell StrictMode
to note the slow call.
And now whoever else touches
my code, and is using it,
and uses StrictMode
as well, if they also
set the detectCustomSlowCalls
thread policy,
again, they will get notified.
Their app will crash.
They will get the log.
And they will know to never
call that generateBoard method
on the main thread.
All right, so what are
some other causes of ANRs?
Be careful if you're
doing any kind
of interprocess communication,
and expect a result.
Don't do it synchronously
on the main thread.
If you're calling some
other application,
if that call is
leading your process,
you basically don't control
what happens on the other side.
IPC goes through layers
of the operating system.
The other process can
access network and disk
to service your request.
So just remember to do it
on the background thread.
The next thing is
multi-threaded programming.
And that's a really,
really difficult topic.
We could have a whole
other session about this.
But if you ever find yourself
touching low level, primitives
such as locks and
synchronization,
eventually, there's
a high chance
you'll create a deadlock
in your application,
or hit some other problem
that blocks your main thread.
And these are very
tricky to debug.
However, Android
Vitals does give you
some information
that will help you
debug these kinds of problems.
So if you open any ANR
in the Vitals console,
we actually provide you
with the trace files,
pulled from the devices that
suffered from these ANRs.
So you can look at
thread states and see
if they were blocked
waiting on any resource
to become available.
And we even highlight
the problems
that we think might be
happening in this trace.
OK, and then last thing I
want to mention is, as a cause
of ANRs, is slow
BroadcastReceiver handling.
Now, not every developer
realizes that if you set up
a BroadcastReceiver in
your Android manifest,
and then it gets cold, that
the onReceive method actually
happens on the main thread.
And you're not supposed to
perform any long running
operations in it.
And there is a time
out, about 10 seconds,
that the system will
allow this method to run.
And then it will
kill your process.
And so sometimes,
though, whenever
you're using a
BroadcastReceiver, maybe
to show a notification
to the user,
maybe you still need
a little piece of data
maybe from the disk, reading
some name or a profile picture
to show you a notification,
so you actually
need to do that
this disk access.
So what can you do in this case?
Now, BroadcastReceivers have
this method called goAsync.
It's basically a way to
tell the BroadcastReceiver
from the onReceive method
that you need to do
some longer running operation.
And then you spin up a
separate thread yourself.
You do the operation,
and then remember
to call finish when you're done.
If you don't do that,
the system will still
realize that you're blocking
and might potentially
kill your app.
And, remember, don't
treat this as some kind
of long running service.
This is not the case
for BroadcastReceivers.
And a reasonable time
limit still applies.
So you should literally just
grab the things you need,
and the separate thread, and
finish as soon as possible
OK, let's talk a little
bit about crashes.
You know, it's really difficult
to give general advice on how
to avoid crashes in
a setting like this,
because every app
will be different.
Every crash will be different.
However, I can give
you some advice
that I think might be helpful.
So for years, as an
Android developer,
I've seen my code, or
code from other people,
start very simple.
And we release something,
and then things
start crashing on
users' devices.
And so we add all
these safety measures,
like checking for nulls
everywhere, and checking
for activity life cycles.
And then if that fails, we just
drop everything in a try-catch,
and just hope that this problem
doesn't hit too many users.
But that's not is not the
greatest solution, right?
It doesn't actually solve
the underlying problem.
And that's why my first
piece of advice to you
is don't try to
reinvent the wheel.
And use readily available
libraries that solve problems
that you, as developers, face.
Now, some of the most
difficult parts of Android--
we heard about it from
you, from developers--
is handling life cycles.
And that's why, last year,
we released the architecture
components such as LiveData,
ViewModel, for handling that.
And also, we released
Room and Paging components
for loading data into your
application, into your UI.
This year at I/O, we're
announcing two new components
as part of the Android
Jetpack initiative.
This is Navigation
for handling all kinds
of fragmented activity
transitions and navigation
problems, and the WorkManager
for scheduling work
in the background.
But, you know, you don't
have to use components
provided by Google.
There are a lot of great third
party libraries out there.
And if you think they're useful
to you and your application
and they will solve
your problems,
feel free to use them as well.
OK, the second thing I want
to mention when talking
about crashes is Kotlin.
Now, also last year
at I/O, we announced
Kotlin as a first class
supported language
for Android developers.
And, before I say
anything more, let
me just say that I know
it's not a silver bullet.
It will not solve all your
crashes in your application.
However, because
of the null safety
that's built right
into the language,
it can save you from some
common classes of errors
that you might
otherwise hit if you
build your apps with just Java.
And some of the other
nice things about Kotlin
are that it's highly
interoperable with existing
Java code.
So you don't have to go all
in and transform all your apps
into Kotlin.
You can start slowly adding
it into your applications
and see if it helps you.
And actually,
developers love Kotlin.
And we are seeing
a steady uptake
in Kotlin usage in Android apps.
And it's also easy
and fun to learn.
So I really encourage, if
you haven't tried it yet,
it's fully supported
by us, and you're
free to use it in
your applications.
And the last thing about crashes
that I want to talk about
is private and hidden APIs.
Now we offer an
SDK to developers
that's backed by
documentation and, basically,
public methods, public
interfaces, that you can use.
But developers are finding
ways to access methods
in the Android framework that
exist on devices that were
never intended for you to use.
And that's not because we
don't like you, as developers,
we don't want to
give you nice things.
It's just because these APIs
are not ready to be used.
They're not guaranteed to exist.
They might be implementation
details on a certain device.
We might even remove them
on the next Android version.
Or a device manufacturer
can go and customize Android
to remove them as well.
The thing is, you should never
use private or hidden APIs
in your apps.
But, in order to enforce
that, and to actually
help you make your
apps crash less,
in case these APIs change,
we're introducing restrictions
and Android P developer
preview that means,
basically, you have to stop
using private and hidden APIs
in your apps.
And we did a similar thing in
Android Nougat with the NDK,
where we said you can no
longer access libraries that
exist on the system
partition if they're not
exposed by public NDK APIs.
So, please, if you can
migrate from private APIs
to public API, they are
documented and guaranteed
to work to make your apps safer.
And let's talk a little bit
about battery and stuck wake
locks.
So wake locks, it's an API
that lets you basically
keep the device from
entering deep sleep, so,
from conserving the battery.
And a stuck wake lock
is when you use the API,
and, because of a
bug, or because you
forgot, you acquire wake lock,
but you never release it.
So it just keeps
the CPU running,
and it keeps draining the
battery on your users' devices.
So what's the best way to
avoid having a stuck wake
lock on your application?
Well, you can't have one if
you don't use wake locks.
That's literally
the simplest thing.
And actually, in modern
Android development,
there's rarely a situation when
you have to use a wake lock.
If we think about activity-- so
whenever the user is actually
using your app, and
for some reason,
you want to keep the screen on--
instead of setting a wake
lock programmatically,
just use a flag on the window
that will tell the system
to keep screen on.
There's no way to leak it.
For services, if
you schedule them
as jobs instead of having your
custom free running services,
the JobScheduler will hold
the wake lock for you.
And so, again, you don't
have to do that yourselves.
Similarly, with
AlarmManager, if you
use it to schedule an alarm
in a BroadcastReceiver,
there will be a wake
lock held for you
for the duration of onReceive.
So if you don't use wake
locks, you don't even
need the permission
in your manifest,
and you can't leak them.
So that's great.
But if you must use
a wake lock, if you
find a situation where
you have to use it,
remember to always choose
a partial wake lock.
All the other
types of wake locks
are deprecated on
your Android versions.
And then, always set a timeout
value in wait wakeLock_acquire
so that, in case you
leak it, the system
will clean up the wake lock for
you after the timeout expires.
Remember to give it a
static, descriptive tag
without any counters,
or, even worse,
private, sensitive information.
That way, we can
service the name
of the wakeLock in
the Android Vitals
for you for easier debugging.
And then remember to always
code defensively, and assume
things can go wrong, and
use things try-and-finally
blocks to make sure that
you release the wake lock as
soon as you're done with it.
And the last thing
I want to talk
about today is
excessive wakeups.
And I think the biggest
cause for excessive wakeups
is the use of this old, old
API called AlarmManager,
and specifically, the
wakeup type of alarms.
Now let me give you the
three Rs of AlarmManager.
Remove calls to wakeup
alarms, if possible.
Reduce the frequency if you have
to use them for some reason.
And, if you can,
replace your alarms
with other APIs, such as
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
whenever the wakeup has to
happen for something that
changed on your server, and you
can send it as a push message.
Or use one of the
job scheduling APIs,
such as the newly announced
WorkManager, or even
JobScheduler or SyncManager.
And with intelligent
job scheduling,
you get a lot of things for
free, such as automatic backoff
and retry, if your job
fails for any reason.
You get criteria
based scheduling,
so you can only wake
up the device when
it has network or is charging,
so that you don't actually
run your code unnecessarily.
You get doze and
standby compliance,
and, like I mentioned
before, even
automatic wake lock handling.
And there's a whole session
about background processing
and WorkManager API specifically
where you can learn more
about this today.
So I mentioned the
Android Profiler before.
And I'm happy to say that
today, in Android Studio,
we're also announcing
the new Energy Profiler,
so that you can debug any kinds
of problems with wake locks,
if you use them in
your app, and also
see detailed information about
alarms and jobs scheduled
in your application.
If you're interested to hear
more about the Profiler,
please go to the
session tomorrow.
And with that, let me
invite Fergus back onstage
to talk to you about what
more you can do to improve
the quality of your apps.
FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks.
Great.
So we've covered
a lot about what's
available in Android
Vitals in the Play Console.
I'm just quickly going to go
through some of the other tools
that you can be able
to use to be able
improve the performance
of your application.
All of Android Vitals
is based on data that's
collected from users' devices.
So these are uses that
are actually being
affected by the issue itself.
We would love for users
not to actually be impacted
by any of these issues at all.
And so we'd encourage you to
do more pre-launch testing
of your application to find
these issues before rolling it
out to users.
There's a session on
this on Thursday at 9:30,
and I encourage you
to attend that one.
Over the past couple of years,
we've made radical improvements
to the Android operating
system to help users
be able to get more out of their
device in terms of performance,
and for the battery
to last longer.
There's major improvements with
the latest version of Android,
and that was covered
in the keynote today.
You can learn a lot more
about that on Thursday
at 11:30 in the session here.
Wojtek covered a bunch
of different tools
within Android
Studio to help you
with improving your core vitals.
But there's a bunch of
other profilers and tools
available to improve all
the rest of your vitals.
And so I encourage you
to use Android Studio,
even if you're using
another ID, for example,
to build your game.
Firebase offers
many tools to help
you be able to track
the performance
of your application, Crashlytics
and Firebase Performance
Monitoring being the most
relevant ones for this talk.
We encourage you
to use those SDKs
if you want to be able to do
custom logging of your issues
that you might be having
with your application.
Note, there will be a
difference in the data that's
collected from the
Firebase SDK versus what's
collected through Android
Vitals, which is from users
who've opted in to sharing
the data with Google
and our partners at [INAUDIBLE].
If you want to learn more about
Firebase Performance Monitoring
and Crashlytics, you can attend
this talk at 11:30 tomorrow.
We covered a lot
in terms of what's
available in Android Vitals
in the Play Console today.
But there's a lot more to learn.
And you can hear
all about that on
developers.android.com/vitals.
Just to quickly
recap, we started
by covering why performance
is vital overall.
And hopefully you
all agree that it is.
That's why you're here
today, so thank you.
Then we covered
what's new in Vitals.
And I hope you take
advantage of these new tools.
Then we talked about how you can
debug these core vitals issues.
And, finally, what's available
beyond Play Console Android
Vitals.
We'd love to hear your
feedback on this talk.
If you can be able to go to
this URL, provide your feedback,
we'd love to hear from you.
If you have any
questions for us,
you can meet us from 4 o'clock
to 5 o'clock at this stand.
It's on the other
side of the lot.
And we'll also be available at
the Google Play Console Sandbox
from 2:00 PM to 5:00
PM tomorrow to answer
any of your questions.
Thank you all very much
for joining us here today.
We hope that you'll make
radical improvements
to your application
over the next year,
and that you'll get covered
in our I/O talk next year.
So, best of luck to you all
with improving your application.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]